[Music]
here in this video we are going to take
a look at the real origins of the mind
flayer and how the soviets that is the
russians managed to capture and
experiment on demo dogs the demogorgon
and even trapping the mind flayer are
now known as the particle being in their
facility so let's get to it
let's start with the origins of the mind
player so from volume 2 of season 4 we
get to see how the mind player came to
be
it was in fact not a malevolent entity
as was seen in the previous three
seasons uh henry creel after the battle
with 11 after he was sent to the upside
down dimension discovered a lot of
species over there untouched by mankind
and as he stated also the most
extraordinary thing of all which was a
swirling storm-like mass of shadowy
particles so using his abilities henry
formed a psychic connection to the
particles and morphed them into a form
that satisfied him he transformed the
mist into a gargantuan spider-like
entity that would come to be known as
the mind flayer
all that we thought we knew about the
mind flayer was wrecked by season four
in my opinion it was a bad direction
that the show runners took instead of
being the omnipotent and all-knowing
ruler of the other dimension it was in
fact revealed to be just another life
form that became a tool for wekner to
exact revenge and eventually try to take
control of the world
now we know that all the demo dogs the
demogorgons the demo bats and even the
mind player were just spawned under the
hands of the master of puppets wagner
so they all exist within a hive mind and
at the center of it all is a psychic
human and not the shadow spider monster
that we all fear and love or what a
bummer
anyway so how did the mind flayer enter
the earthly dimension
well quick answer is through the mother
gate also known as the rift but how did
the russians get it and also trap the
other creatures well this is another
thing entirely another question entirely
so um to start with the rift was a gate
to the upside down located in the
underground section of hawkins lab
created unintentionally by 11
but the soviet union also carried out
their own experiments in
interdimensional travel by inventing a
key that would create enough energy in
opening a gateway however the soviet
gates would briefly open for just a
short amount of time before closing in
and causing a major energy outburst
the only stable rift could be created in
hawkins so that is why in season 3 there
were russians and hawkins and they
managed to open another gate which was
the one below stark god maul and this
led to the spider monster infiltrating
into this world
so yeah season 3's ending had a major
tease of the russians having a
demogorgon of their own and then with
the new season 4 volume 2 this
eventually led to the question of how
the russians acquired the other
creatures as well as the 5 demidocks and
some of the shadow particles of the
mineflayer
so strap yourself up guys for a boring
explanation well now we know that these
creatures are a part of a hive mind with
wekner at the center of it all if one is
hurt the others feel it too keep that in
mind as i try to explain
so when 11 finally confronted and fought
off the spider monster in the mall
wagner 2 was hurt in the process this
led to a disarray in the mental
connection with the troops which are the
demo dogs and the demogorgon and it is
in this fine moment that the russians
managed to capture the weakened
creatures and cage them in massive steel
bars and reinforced bulletproof glass
for the particle monster or at least a
small part of it as seen in the show
well that is the main theory as to how
the soviets got them
but there is another explanation and
that includes the soviet facility slash
prison or gulag where their experiments
were carried out this might have
actually been the place where they the
russians managed to briefly open a
gateway and somehow in that short period
of time a few of the demo dogs entered
the earthly plain
this place is located in the kamchatka
peninsula which is a peninsula located
in the eastern part of russia across the
bering strait from alaska
and on the pacific coast of siberia
also this might explain as to how the
shadowy particles were trapped the
particles could have infiltrated russian
space from one of these gates but when
their connection to the hive mine was
weakened during the battle between 11
and the spider monster this gave the
soviets an opportunity to encase them in
glass
so there are two theories
a one the russians somehow managing to
capture a few demo dogs from their
gateway experiments
from one of their gulags or capturing
the creatures let loose and hawkins
after the battle weakened them which
will also include a small amount of the
mineflayer particles and then trap it in
a reinforced bulletproof glass cubicle
they would then covertly transport them
to kamchatka and why that place well
this would make sense as this region is
far away from any populated area thereby
reducing the chance of casualties if
anything goes wrong and it is remote
enough for them to do as they wish
without being noticed by the public eye
doing it in a golok is another advantage
in itself because with clearance from
the soviet government anything can be
executed in these prison camps monsters
people mind flayer anything
anyway with that we come to the end of
this video tell us what you think if you
agree or not so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family as well as
smash the bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam